whoa reject nation I'm Greg Alba uh
Wendy Lee Wendy Lee from the movie
couple Channel
she was once on Collider she was fired I
want everyone she was fired
I'm taking her position at the new hot
asian girl on collider I feel you should
put like a little glitter all over you
yeah good that's what they do with you
know one day from Collider videos is
here button the movie couple channel
where she has plenty of reactions and
movie reviews on their to make sure to
go check her out her husband Austin it
is a fantastic channel what's up off
these one of these babies yeah alright
we're going to check out the trailer for
this movie that the winning I didn't
hear about but we sided to IMDB it yeah
all the research looking up who's in it
knowledge kids George Clooney wrote and
directed this early but also coded by
the Coen brothers who's holding the
cocoa in his oh and we're together a lot
they do work together either
oh brother where art thou mmm-hmm Burn
After Reading mmm-hmm intolerable
cruelty keep going no more Batman and
Robin come brother's clash the corrected
Terry no idea what it's about though the
one thing we did it with a copy my
losses
yeah and before we go into the reaction
want to give a mention we will be giving
Diego shied as a shadow for patron of
the day welcome to super becomes oh
great wonder excited to it with the
promise of calming ever be for all name
you need to get up
oh you're so beautiful with those men we
decided it'd be best if your auntie
Margaret came and stayed with us you
know what character name was over the
washer if you are into the mom for money
that might explain to your life take
care of the kids
[Music]
oh yeah tip everything from nice to make
decisions like what's best for the
family
Oh any progress on the investigation I'm
officer got killed a couple of days ago
so awesome I'm sorry for his loss
Oh life yeah I guess he thought Opie is
too old
nothing like this ever happened to you
this is a safe place it was
[Music]
Wow I could have a kid Milton could kill
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
nope oh man I need I what so many
thoughts I hope we can be efficient
while talking about this Wendy Lee you
go first that definitely did not go
where I thought it was going to go and I
was like okay president Zell like
somebody has a deep deep dark secret on
their away I didn't think it was going
to get violent and I am okay with it I'm
totally okay with it but II think um
even going through the Coen brothers the
Coen brothers have directed George
Clooney and a lot of stuff so it's
interesting to see them working together
on a script that he's directing and you
can feel all the touches of George
Clooney style like period piece yeah
exploration of that type of era but it
definitely has the Coen brothers dark
comedy time job to it because their
comedies go very dark they tend to get
violent it has all that and I love the
setting of it being in like 1950s
Pleasantville but with a direct period
atmosphere around everybody has a dark
secret oh yeah I go meet that anger
issue
and the comedy banter looks really on
par yeah Matt Damon I haven't been
excited for him in a role and so long
yeah well it seems like Tiffany did a
great wall yeah I didn't see that
there's dangerous Clooney's last movie
but I feel like George Clooney's movies
that he directs I haven't seen a movie
that dealt with like you know
interesting violent type of plot since
worst movie confessions of a dangerous
mind yeah and this one it's like I feel
like we'll get a different style of
George Clooney they were having gone in
any of his movies because they're
usually just character pieces that have
exploration in the air this seems to
have that plus a really intriguing plot
yeah I am just done so interested if you
see where the character goes from like
where Matt Damon's character goes
towards an office to it finally you see
that switch happens and it's so good
because it's so distinct and I feel like
for his kids you know yes he's bloody
eating at the anyways like what's going
on through the kids minds yeah it's kind
of like a Breaking Bad type of vibe of
like this father it was like a really
good type of guy who's breaking into the
darker side of life going after the
like a dark LA Confidential style with
Coen Brothers humor indoors Clooney
touch - it is shiny and more - your
immigrant type of leg with the blonde
wig and everything it seems like a
different type of character yeah she's
one of those actresses I can blend into
any era - an Oscar Isaac man and him
being a part of this gasps - I love
Oscar eyes yeah every time you've been
in Ex knocking off Star Wars I feel like
you know some ways George Clooney
because these work with Soderbergh a lot
- and I could see some a Steven
Soderbergh flares yeah here as well even
after you watch like the lowly lucky
trailers then you see this trailer yeah
yeah similar touches that he has so I
feel a lot of inspiration coming
together for this one story within that
Damon led performance oh man when it is
coming out November 3rd right after
Halloween
oh I'm excited I'm so excited for this
oh and before I tell you to subscribe to
the movie couple channel the most
important thing you must do if there's
any take away you get from this video it
is going to be the outro part where I
tell you to subscribe to the move a
couple channel subscribed movie couple
channel Diego Chaidez shout out of that
day buddy
Diego shy Dez he has the reward here
where he can be part of the Google
Hangouts oh wow and he has not been even
part of the paper after like over a
month now I'm he hasn't joined cash in
it I don't know what it's like you're
pledging money but yet you haven't you
don't want to talk to I mean you're
really intimidating you know I give off
bad vibes I give off that I feel like
I'm not approachable I'm like I'm really
masculine and I know that can intimidate
something like Diego who is actually a
competing jujitsu fighter well so he's
probably just a major [ __ ] that's the
way to get it are coming out with you
guys actually looking yeah yeah come
talk to them being on there's no patron
today shoutouts are all about
subscribers are it already text group a
notification Ville and I don't think I
mentioned it yet but make sure to check
out the movie couple channel with Wendy
Lee and her husband Bradley go check
them out they're so good together I'm
hoping they stay together for everyone's
sake and yeah we have a patreon bye